uh
foreign
okay
thank you for joining us the conclusions
have been adopted and we will publish
them shortly like with a yesterday
president of the european council please
merci merci beaucoup
we indeed
made every
i want to encourage every effort take
every
measure to bring
this war to an end
uh as regards the key points we covered
today the food security was a
particularly important point we invited
president maki sal
who is the
president of the african union currently
to discuss with african representatives
how the european union and the african
union could cooperate as effectively
as possible
to meet this
challenge that we jointly face to take
measures
to support
the african countries in the spirit of
partnership to help improve strengthen
the production capacities in africa
and also to ensure
supporting measures
so that one can help avert
this
potentially serious crisis for a number
of countries it could have a
a a harmful effect in africa but also in
europe that's one element and you see
the detailed conclusions of that
uh today is the energy and we all know
this is a fundamental challenge for all
of us just extremely important on the on
the one hand to discuss uh on the
proposals
put on the table by the commission in
order to to prepare the following steps
we power eu is a very important
initiative we had the occasion to
exchange views uh and to uh and to make
progress on that uh topic and especially
we understand this is extremely
important to um work uh on
on the possibility and and to explore
the possibility of import price caps
also with international partners we
intend also to act in four key areas the
diversification diversified fuels and
sources
in the renewables to speed up renewables
is of course
fundamental but also to work in the
field of energy efficiency to save
energy
is of course a fundamental priority for
all of us and we are also determined to
invest in infrastructure in energy
interconnections and of course in
renewable we need also to improve our
preparedness for possible major supply
disruptions and we have also
asked the commission to work on the
optimization of the functioning of the
european electricity
market
so the
on energy was an opportunity to reaffirm
our determination
to pick up this challenge as europeans
now we face this challenge before the
war in ukraine but even more so now
because of the ongoing war in ukraine
and then finally
the third point
i wanted to to mention concerning
european defense you will see the
conclusions too
in this field
we share the view share the view around
the table that we need to spend and
invest more on defense and to do so not
just more but also better
to act more effectively better together
as europeans
for involving for example grouped uh
procurement and also
our serious effort to strengthen
europe's industrial
base in this field taking account in
particular of the role of european smes
which can play
a key role in this process it was also
an opportunity to reaffirm
the importance of
what
complementarity between what the eu does
and what nato does there will be a
summit in madrid
and this would
no doubt be an opportunity to reaffirm
this complementarity between the
european union and nato so these are
some of the key points i wanted to share
with you
in the immediate aftermath of the
european council which has just
concluded madam precedent
you might remember that in versailles
the leaders decided to phase out the
dependency on russian fossil fuels as
soon as possible
we started with coal
yesterday in the middle of the night we
decided then to have a ban now on de
facto 90 percent of russian oil
imports to the european union by the end
of the year
and this comes at a time when we see
that russia has disrupted supplies to by
now five member states
um you know finland bulgaria and
poland
but now to a company in the netherlands
and to a company in denmark
so our answer has to be very clear how
are we going to manage
and what is the road map to really
get rid of the dependency of russian
fossil fuels and here with view to gas
the answer is repower eu
it brings basically three different
pillars um that we have discussed today
the first one is the diversification
away from russian fossil fuels
specifically on gas
here we now have set up a joint task
force for common purchases joint
purchases of gas because the market
power of the whole of 27 in the european
union is much bigger than every single
member state and we will achieve better
conditions
we have of course already since the
beginning of the year started to look
out for other more reliable suppliers
and this effort is already paying off we
see it today that the lng deliveries
from other parts of the world others
than russia
have doubled in queue one in 2022
compared for example to the previous
year
the second element we are working on in
repower eu is the security of supply
through better interconnections
so that the gas can flow wherever it is
needed
and of course the common objective to
have a more strategic
storage across a gas storage across the
european union here we have good news
our gas storage is already filled at 41
of the capacity this is five percentage
points higher than it was the case last
year
at the same date
and then the third is the most important
pillar and this is the massive
investment in renewables it's
accelerating the deployment of
renewables across the european union
the renewable energy has the big
advantage that it is not only good for
the climate
but it is also good for our independence
and good for our security of supply and
it creates jobs at home
so for this plan
we power eu
we have been discussing with the council
european council we are proposing to
support it with 300 billion euros from
eu funding there are different
parts that are contributing to this
funding if there are any questions about
me i'm very happy to respond to them but
this is the house of repower eu that we
have presented and discussed today
basically it is solidarity and
cooperation that are at the heart of any
successful strategy to deal
with russia as a non-reliable supplier
anymore
cooperation for example as has been
demonstrated by denmark germany the
netherlands and belgium
who
a couple of days ago
showed at a joint wind summit what it
means to develop develop the wind power
the offshore wind power in the north sea
and of course solidarity this was a big
topic today ensuring that in case of a
full disruption of gas flows from russia
gas is indeed allowed to flow to
wherever it is needed in europe
the second topic
was this defense
the war again
wasn't is a stark reminder
for our member states on the need to
strengthen our defence capacities
we have seen positive developments
notably of course we are all aware of
finland's and sweden's application to
join nato nato the strongest military
alliance in the world
and they will benefit greatly from their
membership
but also the fact that since the
beginning of the war
leaders and the member states stepped up
and announced by now 200 billion euros
in extra military spending
now it is important that we ensure that
these
stepping up and additional investment
we get the maximum value out of it
and we all know the challenges that
exist
within the european union or the
european model
on one hand it is the lack of of
investment over the last years so the
gaps have to be filled
but the bigger challenge is the
fragmentation we have within the
european defense industry and the
dublication of weapon systems
here we see that this leads to increased
cost to reduce interoperability so we
have to improve this situation
and therefore it is first of all helpful
that since the beginning of this mandate
the european defense fund is up and
running it's a strong incentive to work
together
the pilot program so far
have benefited to more than 600 entities
and 26 member states have used so far
the european defense fund this is an
encouraging start
but there's also a second element now
when we replenish
the military material that has been sent
to ukraine for example it is important
that this is coordinated and for that
we're setting up a task force
to coordinate also to deconflict the
replenishment of the national stockpiles
and the commission will propose before
end of june to mobilize 500 million
euros over the next two years from the
eu budget to incentivize
the joint procurement by at least three
member states
this is let's say a pilot for a longer
term proposal that will come
in the course of this year for a
european defense investment program
finally
the third topic
was on food security charles introduced
in the whole topic already at the moment
being we're facing one overriding
urgency and that is 20 million tons of
wheat are stuck in ukraine and they have
to get out
and therefore we have created and we're
working hard on the solidarity lines
lanes
that will enable it to bring out parts
of this wheat through land route and
trains towards our parts
it is not trivial and it is of course
more tedious and expensive but it is
necessary to get this wheat out
the second point that is important that
we now give relief to the vulnerable
populations and um
the possibility to afford the food
for that we have pledged two and a half
billion euros
and we mobilize uh we propose to
mobilize reserves from the european
development fund to support for example
sub-saharan africa
the third element in that is that we
step up our own food production
we expect a record export of cereals of
40 million tons in 22 and 23.
within this scenario
we call on all partners not to restrict
global trade on agricultural products
so any kind of trade restrictions have
absolutely no place in our member states
or globally
and finally
but this is the mid and long term we
really have to develop
better strategies uh for example in
north africa and sub-saharan africa to
increase the production and the
resilience with new technologies
precision farming the nanotechnologies
that are there so a lot of topics that
are combined to this food topic
from the urgency to the mid and to the
long term
we will coordinate all our actions with
the team europe approach
to feed into this work
i will travel to cairo mid-june
to discuss all these issues with
president al-sisi
because we have to look at them not only
from a european ukraine perspective but
also from a regional and bilateral
perspective many thanks
thank you madam president
okay thomas you are next
desolate secretary
export from from ukraine do you see any
chances that all these solidarity lines
and calls for the eu member states to
for help in in the export could add up
to the capacity sufficient for exporting
ukrainian with this year this this this
summer
if not because it seems for now it's too
too too little what would be your
comment on these ideas of of
transporting the wheat through
through belarus
uh on the price of it through various
baltic states and if not do you see any
diplomatic possibility to
convince or to make uh russians to to
unblock odessa or to export the wheat
thank you no you are absolutely right it
should be the the first priority because
there are 22 millions of tons of grains
that are blocked in ukraine especially
in odessa and a few weeks ago when i
went to this site the occasion to see
with my own ice was the situation on the
ground and for instance countries like
egypt and other countries
in africa
they are victims of this this situation
it means that we fully support all the
efforts made by the united nations in
order to find an agreement
uh to open a maritime corridor to the
black through the black sea it would be
the best option in order to make sure it
is possible to export grains but we are
not certain we are certain it will work
we hope it'll be possible to get an
agreement on that important topic and
that's why we are also working based on
the proposal of the commission on
those
green lanes
in order to facilitate alternative
routes and with the leaders
today and yesterday we discussed the
different possibilities in order to
develop alternative routes but we know
that it's more difficult it's more
expensive it's more difficult for
obvious logistic
reasons
and we try to facilitate
in order to in order to uh to reduce the
initiative burdens which also which is
also an important question about belarus
and the access
towards the baltic sea
we understand that there are also tolls
at the level of the united nations on
that on that topic
and we support all these efforts but
in the short term we don't see a
concrete a concrete result a concrete
achievement and you know that we have
decided uh sanctions on belarus on the
on the potassium fertilizers uh for
instance and we finns is very important
to maintain the pressure against the
kremlin but also against belarus because
we feel that this country is helping a
lot uh russia
in the in in the framework of this war
launched by russia against ukraine yeah
um only little to add um
charles described indeed our
efforts or the international efforts in
the black sea
it is important not to underestimate the
work we can do now and we are doing now
indeed these 20 million tons are there
on average ukraine exported in normal
times 5 million tons per month
now we are at least at a range between
200 000 and 1 million ton per month with
these measures of the green lanes for
example very tedious very difficult
lots of effort but it's something you
can do right now and we are doing right
now while the other efforts for the
bigger picture of course are still
ongoing
yuri
you are next
uh yes thank you very much yuri shikoh
ukrainian service of deutsche welle uh i
have a question first from about the
embargo on oil
it of course it's great that the you
reach this deal but
if you look at the message it sends to
russia it looks like it says to russia
that russia has still time six eight
more months to continue destroying
ukraine till the embargo starts
enters into force
and it says like russia has all this
time in order to find other buyers for
this oil so my question is uh which
message do you see it sends to
russia and how it helps to stop war now
and the second question is also because
you discussed today a lot of
energy uh what do you see ukraine is
connected to
uh european continental electricity grid
already for a couple of months
uh and i know that the work is going on
the commercial of selling of ukrainian
electricity to the eu countries so what
which perspective do you see i think
it's rather too
far from the lion question which
perspective do you see here how
soon it might start this commercial
trade of electricity with ukraine and
how can it help also europe in its
energy transition thank you very much i
think it was an outstanding success that
we were able to connect the electricity
grid that fast
you must know that
in february and february beginning of
march there was a planned
decoupling
of the ukrainian electricity grid from
the russian electricity grid with
initially the plan to recouple again and
take two years to then join the european
union
of course when the war hit it was
absolutely impossible to recouple
ukraine to the russian grid
and we managed within two weeks
to couple the ukrainian grid to the
european european one and this was and
is a big success
and therefore
i think it also shows that we have
ongoing war work during the war
that always um improves and supports the
situation of ukraine so it's very
important not only to stare at the war
which is atrocious and horrible
but to never give up on doing the daily
work to improve the situation of ukraine
itself for your wider question
um i think we have to look at two points
um it is a wind down period
uh in six to eight months till the end
of the year so it's not an abrupt and
full speed
uh supply during that time and then
abrupt end but
a clear reduction of oil already
one
figure i have on the top of my head is
for example germany
told us that since the beginning of the
year where they started with 35 russian
oil they are already down to 12
russian oil this shows that by just
working hard on not renewing contracts
finishing contracts and looking at other
suppliers you can fill this wind down
period
much better and most importantly in the
back is of course the whole big package
of six sanctions and these sanctions are
biting hard
and uh are really um
destroying and that's the the goal uh
the basis the financial basis of putin
leading this war and hitting hard the
russian economy
i would like to also to a few words
about this important question because uh
i think that when we were in versailles
a few weeks ago not many observers would
have thought that it would have been
possible for us only in a few weeks
to take such a concrete and strange
decision
we have decided to sanctions russia by
banning
old is extremely important and we will
succeed in the following months to
implement that decision and ursula
is right when she said that it will
break the financing of the russian war
machine this is our goal and we have two
tools that we have that we are using as
much as we can on the one hand we
support ukraine with military treatment
with financial support with material
with political support as much as we can
also when we engage with third countries
in order to have
more support at the international level
point one and point two we have decided
on five packages of sanctions and the
last one was the the that we have
decided yesterday what's more difficult
because this is about energy and energy
is a big topic it's a big thing for the
members for the households for the
families for the businesses and that's
why we have decided to work on solutions
on concrete solutions in order to make
sure that the decisions we are taking
are painful for russia for the kremlin
this is our main goal
daniel question philip
passes
sorry a bit of a trip to get here from
le soir question for both of you
do you share the view of certain member
states that with this sixth package
it's time to take a break when it comes
to the sanctions
to look at what the effects of these
sanctions are because it's also got a
price tag or do you think as others
believe that it's now time to prepare
the way for the seventh package now you
said yesterday that corporate on
wednesday would probably complete all
the work so the sixth package could
enter into force already on wednesday or
thursday can you confirm that date the
second question is with regard to food
security
moscow keeps repeating that uh the cause
of all this evil is of course the
western sanctions the fact that we're
not letting their vessels
into our ports and
also
what's happening around
odessa do you think that that is a
massive trap
they want to de-mine odessa so that they
can then get access themselves to the
port well on that less question on
odessa
of course there has to be a security
guarantee there we can't have a maritime
corridor for humanitarian reasons
weakening the security situation in
ukraine obviously we would support the
position of ukraine each and every time
they try to defend their legitimate
security concerns
and secondly yesterday we had a debate
which had been prepared and the run-up
to that for the sixth package of
sanctions and we are now focusing on the
implementation of this six package now
that doesn't mean that there are
opinions out there
different members of the council have
different opinions but we are focusing
now on this sixth package and as i
indicated yesterday uh the legal texts
are being drafted and the procedure
therefore can take off as of tomorrow so
the text will be sent to or invalidated
tomorrow evening or the day after so it
could just be a question of hours
with the legal drafting of the text but
i can confirm that as of
tomorrow where the legal texts will be
there and can be addressed to all the
corrupter members
the question is concerned on
six package and the follow-up
i think
on one hand we have to look at the
russian economy and financial market
and on the other hand on
the big resources to the russian
government that is energy
fossil fuel energy
and we have now clearly addressed
the three topics of coal oil and gas
with two sanctioned packages
and repower eu
and the six sanctioned packages are also
of course addressing the financial
sector and
hurting it heavily the same goes for the
russian economy
and for me is important now after having
put in place the structure on the energy
element that we look in the financial
and the economic sector of russia
whether there are attempts of
circumventions now
or trying to move away from this
situation
and therefore i would not exclude that
we over and over will have to redress
the situation we address the situation
that we close loopholes that we stop
circumventions so that we keep on
working on that
but the big bulk on energy this is up
and running this is on the road in what
we've just described
on the
food looming food crisis
that the fact that there is a severe
food crisis developing
is
only the fault of russia's unjustified
war
without this war we would not have it
and we should always over and over
repeat that um
russia is not only blocking the expert
of export of
ukrainian wheat it is bombarding
warehouses where wheat is stored
deliberately
of course you know that they are also
mining the fields where ukraine could
have the next harvest
of corn
and i want to be very clear we have no
sanctions on food and agricultural
products no sanctions on that
and important also if you is speaking
about fertilizers for example third
countries have access to all the
fertilizers for example from russia
this was a clear decision
that we say humanitarian goods and food
agriculture wheat of course is a part of
it
no sanctions on it so it's a complete
misinformation from russia's side the
only reason
why we are struggling now with the food
crisis is because of this brutal
unjustified war against ukraine
thank you madam president this concludes
our press conference it's a matter of
minutes for the publication of the
conclusions
excuse me